Аніка Фальке - дизайнерка продуктів. Будинок своєї мрії вона збудувала собі сама.
Я живу в тайні-хаусі - такому собі міні-будинку. Раніше я будувала декорації для кіно, це щось зовсім інше.
Коли я звільнилася, я вирушила в мандри. Все, що я мала, вмістилося в один рюкзак.
Ідея з тайні-хаусом - це щось подібне.
Ти маєш усе, що тобі потрібно, можна все скомбінувати в одному просторі,
всюди є якісь схованки і все багатофункціональне.
Шеф Аніки 5 років тому почав будувати тайні-хауси. Тепер він один з найбільших виробників міні-будинків у Німеччині.
На рік він будує 40 таких будинків максимальною площею 25 квадратних метрів.
Уперше я побачив їх у Канаді. Я тривалий час мешкав там і спостерігав, як вони там будують.
У принципі це маленькі помешкання, вони ще не були на колесах. Така концепція здалася мені вкрай привабливою.
А далі ця хвиля прийшла з Північної Америки в Європу.
І тоді ми доволі рано підключилися до цього і сказали: ми збудуємо прототип і випробуємо це.
Щонайменше 45 тисяч євро коштує такий будинок. Деякі клієнти хочуть прожити в ньому ціле життя.
Інші потребують лише для відпочинку. Зрозуміло одне: багато манатків сюди не вмістиш.
Мінімалізм, скорочення своїх пожитків стало трендом у значній частині суспільства.
Ми з цим стикаємося, тому що маємо багато клієнтів, які цим цікавляться.
І скорочення житлової площі - це просто частина теми мінімалізму, скорочення свого особистого відбитку СО2.
І в цю концепцію добре вписується, що можна жити і обігрівати не 60 квадратних метрів, а, можливо, лише 20.
В інших куточках світу житлова площа у 20 квадратних метрів вважається стандартом, а то й розкішшю, як-от у Гонконзі.
Багато людей живуть тут у крихітних приміщеннях, бо більше їм просто не по кишені.
Архітектор Джеймс Лоу родом з Гонконгу. Він будує так звані о-поди - це міні-квартири з бетонних труб.
Одного разу ця ідея спала мені думку, коли я стояв на своїй будові і побачив переді мною величезні труби для води.
Я зайшов в одну і помітив, що вони достатньо великі. Тоді я подумав: це вже архітектура, це вже як приміщення.
Трохи дизайну і креативності - і це може швидко перетворитися на житло.
Джеймс Лоу хоче будувати такі будинки насамперед для безхатченків та соціально незахищених людей.
Перші 120 мають з'явитися в Гонконгу вже цього року.
Архітектор переконаний, що слід думати глобально.
Адже за умов швидкого зростання світового населення людству доведеться будувати маленькі квартири замість великих, аби всім вистачило місця.
Міста стали настільки дорогими, що важко знайти житло, бо так багато людей розпачливо шукає якісь варіанти.
І будинки, які ми нині будуємо, багато хто просто не може собі дозволити.
Можливо, така форма мінімалізму стане необхідною у багатьох містах.
Ми не можемо просто далі будувати дедалі більші і дедалі монументальніші проєкти як символ міста.
Ми мусимо також подбати про людей, інакше в підсумку вони будуть потерпати.
Гонконг - це лише один приклад переповненого міста, в якому житлова площа стала майже безцінною.
Таких міст ставатиме дедалі більше. Штефан Дікманн переконаний: майбутнє ринку нерухомості - за тайні-хаусами.
Гадаю, люди нині стали більш гнучкими, більше не прив'язані так сильно до одного місця,
і тому такі міні-будинки стають дедалі привабливішими.
Дікманн хоче скористатися бумом і планує відкрити готель з таких міні-будиночків,
як тільки пандемія дозволить. Різні моделі вже готові.
А от її переконувати більше не треба: Аніка Фальке більше ніколи не хоче повертатися в традиційне житло.
Затишку тайні-хауса вистачить їй на ціле життя.